CBS News has confirmed that North Korea
gave the Trump administration a two
million dollar bill for the hospital
care of American hostage otto warmbier
later died in the United States the
University of Virginia student was
sentenced to 15 years of hard labor in
prison after he was accused of taking a
propaganda poster during a visit to
beyond yang warmbier was sent home in a
coma back in 2017
now the u.s. says it never intended to
pay the bill but it was signed for we
should Jiang is at the White House we
should this is just unbelievable to hear
that we are now being billed for otto
warmbier it's such a tragic story oh you
know the agreement was made under former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson and his
successor Secretary Mike Pompeo has made
clear at his US policy not to pay for
hostages now this clash is the latest
stumbling block in talks with North
Korea to get rid of its nuclear weapons
I think without Otto this would not have
happened
president Trump has said otto warmbier
was central to the dialogue with kim
jeong-hoon that led to their ongoing
discussions about denuclearizing North
Korea
Otto is someone who did not die in vain
the former US envoy to North Korea
joseph hyun signed the two million
dollar bill to cover warm beers hospital
care but the State Department says the
United States never paid it and never
intended to press secretary Sarah sander
said in a statement we do not comment on
hostage negotiations warmbier died June
1920 17 days after he was flown home to
Ohio relatives believe that 21 year old
was tortured this news that the North
Koreans wanted two million dollars for
medical equipment I think is outrageous
former New Mexico Governor Bill
Richardson took part in the first round
of negotiations to recover warm beer
typical North Korean negotiating tactics
the president has repeatedly refused to
specifically condemn kim jeong-hoon for
the tragedy I don't think that the top
leadership knew about it during their
second summit in Vietnam this February
mr. Trump said he spoke to Kim about
warm beers death he tells me that he did
know about it and I will take him at his
word that trust may be crumbling North
Korean state TV reports Kim told Russian
President Vladimir Putin during their
summit yesterday the u.s. acted in bad
faith during those talks in Hanoi that
collapsed at the last minute the White
House is not commenting on Kim's claim
but a senior administration official
tells me President Trump seemed blase
about the summit between Putin and Kim
and didn't ask top aides to acquire a
readout John Louisa thank you